Why Do Zippers Have YKK on Them?
The YKK stands for Yoshida Kogyo Kabushikikaisha
(say that five times fast).
In 1934 Tadao Yoshida founded Yoshida Kogyo
Kabushikikaisha (translated Yoshida Industries
Limited).
This company is now the world’s foremost
zipper manufacturer, making about 90% of all
zippers in over 206 facilities in 52 countries.
In fact, they not only make the zippers, they
also make the machines that make the zippers;
no word on if they make the machines that
make the parts that make up the machines that
make the zippers.
Their largest factory in Georgia makes over
7 million zippers per day.
In any event, Mr. Yoshida’s company zipped
to number one by practicing the “Cycle of
Goodness”, as he called it.
Namely, “No one prospers unless he renders
benefit to others.”
Using this principle, he endeavored to create
the best zippers out there that would hold
up over long periods of time in the end product.
This in turn would benefit both the manufacturers
who used his zippers and the end customer
and because of these things benefit his company
with higher repeat and referral sales, thus
completing the “Cycle of Goodness” *zen
moment*
So next time you’re zipping up, take a moment
to remember Mr. Yoshida; also, if you’re
going commando, careful with Captain Winky
on the zip up.
I can’t stress that enough.